hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to critical annihilation
there's the full release of a game
called critical mass that I played a
while ago where it brought a very
interesting and unique and probably
familiar song to the forefront that went
Bennett dad I
I don't know I'm singing it when I could
be playing for you so here it is the
song that I've been using me I no one
notices yet and plenty of people have I
use that exclusively for the horror game
the outros that I play I play different
outro music for different types of games
I played between fun games and horror
games they have different ones as a
horror game one made by shirk cool guy
check out his music but this is critical
annihilation and they sent me some keys
for this one and I'm going to play it
and I'm gonna blow [ __ ] up because it
has been a long day and I am incredibly
tired so here we go I think out first
encounter hell yeah ok so this is where
things get tricky yeah it's back when I
had pink hair which may be coming back
cuz after I dye my hair red which
probably gonna happen I'm going to like
steadily let it fade down to pink so it
should be good I'm pretty sure I got the
most strength possible in a character
I'm here and this one's really cool
because a very beautiful game that's
voxel based and this is actually kind of
familiar to what I was first encounter
the first time that aliens land upon
this planet
let's show them our love to the feeling
of bullets and their chests if they even
have chest to blow apart
this game is
I mean I'm not a fan of dubstep or
whatever this may be but that's one of
the things that drew me to the first
game was its intense
thumping soundtrack it's that music was
so unbelievably cool that I just played
the game so that I could listen to the
song over and over and over again okay
then I set up a nuke in my pants
hope y'all were ready for that one the
other cool thing is that I was quite
good at this game
I got a pretty high score not the
highest score but even though that I
could have gotten the high score
considering that I'm the greatest gamer
ever did live in the face of gaming in
my nose is quite growing very long now
I'm terrible at games what am I don't
you know you're messing with Wilfred
Wharf smash the greatest reporter ever
report on the alien invasion I just
realized this is how Wilfred works Ashe
would have would attend to the first
aliens landing on the planet my god
I can hardly believe alien bastards are
tossing their bodies more than my bullet
truly inferiorly people have been asking
when the next guy on the next Wilford
wharfs s gets is gonna come out and we
may bring it back because it's been a
while admittedly as and I I don't want
to forget about work - as a character
because he is a super cool dude and a
total maniac and he's like devolved from
being an actual reporter who reported on
important things and then being
absolutely terrible in murdering but he
comes across in horrible ways which is
exactly while I'm doing
no one Tombo where they're zombies
having aliens taking over the zombies I
mean humans and turn them into zombies
more important questions to be asked
here okay now the secret that whoa hey
the secret of this character has kaboom
is an I have a marker gun I don't know
how to use it is that in there we go oh
my god that's almost too silly
it's a poop gun it's a gun that poops
out mustaches oh I'm such a nerd
oh I'm such a goddamn nerd oh look at me
why do head door this oh it's like
killing them with love except they still
bleed and die oh it's amazing the other
thing about this game is they they
teamed up with scherk who made the music
for the original one and I'm willing to
guess I haven't played the game but
fully I'm willing to guess that the
soundtrack is exactly as thumping and
dope and sick beats I don't know the
game is amazing and you should play by
the way it's very late we've had a long
day Wade came into town and we've just
been catering to his every whim since he
got here and it's been nothing but going
out and trying to film videos we just
got done filming videos we just got back
from a great improv show with lots of
cool stuff happening and actually at
this show was a person by the name of
Heather Anne Campbell who I know from
whose line is it anyway I don't know if
earnestly but she was unbelievably funny
in that show so kudos out to Heather
Anne Campbell goodness gracious that was
so funny that show I was almost dying
laughing I thought I was standing right
by the side of the stage I thought I was
annoying to heaven with how loud I was
laughing because again it's very
clicking and I'm very tired and this was
an 11 o'clock show 11 o'clock show yeah
very good show adults only but also just
because Oh who's
funny just what they were able to grab
from it and it's like it inspires me
because that's how I want to be as a
comedian I think everyone in their
mother wishes just wishes that they were
funnier and man I know I'm not to that
point just yet but God I really hope
that as I start learning and as I
continue to learn things about comedy
and about interrupts and everything else
that I could be doing like I really hope
I really really really hope that I can
even come to a fraction I'm dead
I come to fractions I practices I got
trapped all over the sands snow I hope I
hope that I can be that funny someday oh
oh god I gotta get to the bomb oh I got
dropped the base all over your faces out
of the bomb went away never mind I got
sad points what I can level up god I was
a bit too antsy about that one but
that's amazing I need to get speed up oh
I should probably use my shield
shouldn't I be smart but I'm not smart
I'm incredibly stupid I've got nothing
left the years in my brain cuz it's all
been [ __ ] it out from spending so much
time with Wade listening to puns like
drains your IQ point by point hon by pun
you can feel yourself getting dumber and
dumber and dumber and dumber and as you
spend more and more time with Wade I
love way to death he's a delightful
person he's one of my best friends could
rely on him for anything but the god
damn he is a sadist when he comes to the
pain he inflicts with his horrible puns
Bank Bank bank banks
spank banks bang bang bang bang
something different I'm sure others
didn't talk about that
there we go that cleans them up I just
want someone to make a mod about this
vulnerability shield
oh yeah sounds great how do I use that
can I get that please okay my rocket
launcher I'll do rockets oh oh that's
amazing I forgot about that that was
part of critical mass - how can I forget
that
oh man the music did change so cool yes
rise again I don't know if they could
have stopped me if I was up here no what
is that I don't know what that is but I
love it oh I can call in airstrikes oh
that's so cool Oh
oh my god here comes the part where I'm
just gonna be non-stop talking about how
cool it is so cool Oh
frickin dick freak my dick you alien
[ __ ] oh oh man it's so cool what is
that
double experience awesome see this is
why and harkening back to the old whoa I
forgot that I said that plasma shield
and invulnerability shield nice nice
nice nice nice nice nice nice Mike
thank you thank you goodbye I'm the best
you're the worst whatever shut up yes
oh hello who the hell are you no no I
said
no take a whole lot of note of the face
[ __ ] hey that's right I'm the greatest
you're the worst how's that taste
how's that taste all over your face
great I am okay so that is critical
annihilation there's a lot more game to
play here I don't know if it's actually
fully released I'm pretty sure it is it
can be bought on Steam it does cost
money the original critical mass did not
and I don't know if that's a demo
available I don't know a lot like I said
very late I'm very tired
but this game is fun I know what fun is
and this is exactly that so check it out
for yourself thank you so much for
putting me in the game thank you so much
for letting me use your music in my have
trust in all my videos it really made
them a lot better so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video